today we are joined by the hall of fame
of among us players
video game donkey who is a master at all
video games
leah world champion of tetris
1997. gus sure who won
the pong championship 1973
and eddie the tekken 17
world second place runner-up already on
tekken 17th
today we are joined for the among us
championship with 10 players
to see who will reign supreme the
imposter extraordinaire
eli are we ordering pizza yes or no
before hurry before sure
do you want italian dressing or veto's
let's get vito's balsamic dressing
we're in the game uh i'm hungry
eli do you want a cannoli you lost your
privilege
what i'm ordering pizza in case anyone
suspects me
[Music]
dan's trying to kill me come on hold on
i called you a meeting i called this
meeting
i just want to say i just spent a
hundred dollars on a pizza and i have no
idea
it was just a fresh mozzarella pie with
black olives helping new broccoli that
was 50 bucks
and i got a salad that was 20 bucks
delivery fee is 20
and i left a 20 tip i don't want to get
past
the fact that you ordered a broccoli
olive
and mozzarella cheese pizza and i don't
mean to pass judgment but i think i
speak for all of us when i say
guy the broccoli is a life hack because
it make
it lightens up the pizza and you can eat
more slices thank you feeling very
distracted now and very hungry
we're all very serious here about the
game the second this is over dan is
about to kill me this man is
out here following me again like he's
actually doing it this time
before that was a lie but now he's doing
it for real
guys let's skip it let's get let's get
this yeah
ethan has more pizza news
mozzarella sticks
i didn't kill you babe you should get
pizza
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody's order everybody order pizza
come on everybody
[Music]
i'm scared
these [ __ ] are ready already
acting up
already being sacrificed
one down
perfect timing i don't know where the
body was reported but i saw
dan last with gus and ela following
actually illa got locked out of the door
so if gus and dan wanted the electrical
gus got that kill
i'm not in electrical right now
bruh she got no doubt i did my job at
the top right of electrical and then
i've since left
and then i went back through storage
again did you see gus leave
i don't know who i saw but i was gonna
go in after some people and then
the door got locked right yeah i saw
that happen yeah i can definitely clear
uh leah i saw her doing weapons and
uh as i was coming down from weapons to
shields i
passed uh donkey
right before finding the body i saw him
as well he lurked behind me just for a
second but he's been pretty innocent to
me
yeah i'm pretty innocent guys how did
you hear more from gus
gus yeah anything that's you the doors i
saw you and dan walk toward electrical
ela followed the door is locked and now
dan is dead
and you said you left but the door's
locked yeah i mean i totally get that i
went up there and i had the one quick
job in there we just do the quick flip
and then i've since gone down and right
through storage again a quick
job was it part of your job to kill
someone
[Laughter]
i'm saying i'm thinking about gus
because what they're killing they're
really clear
i don't have anything to do you gotta go
for
everybody should say enjoy space idiot
this is a trap isn't it just for the
record before you guys talk
i could hear leah just yeah let you guys
know i feel like
what i heard from leah is kind of like
spoiling i'm sorry i just i feel like i
kind of know now and i don't want to say
any
yeah i think i did kind of give it away
that it's eddie
there's no way is it donkey
it could be i was doing human stuff
damn it jason sorry it was just
i heard what she said donkey's mike
picked up you
[Music]
she never mutes
would you guys have voted for donkey if
he didn't say i was doing human things
kind of gave it away yeah because you
guys all turned on him
if anything that helped his case oh
all right good guy gus here let's try to
do some god look at these jobs on the
map there's a thousand of them here
i hope i'm not the first to die again oh
i'm gonna see if he did it
who did two dads true already
so i just saw zach as the body
survival attack i still have a front
phone
i'm skipping now but keep your eyes on
gus guys why'd you kill them
i'm not supposed to keep my eye on you
no yeah i think i suspected
ela gus elan gusts
all right they better not kill me here
why is ethan still here too okay
oh no what is eli doing
my suspicions were correct okay gus is
dead so he's
not gus apologies there gus
okay i feel like i don't have solid
enough evidence i think it's healing i
definitely gotta get these passed down
i don't wanna snitch anybody out but dan
was following me
for about okay dan's been pretty much
been one minute he was following me
okay skip and do your task i think i
think it's
for sure sorry elo wow
teddy it's dan it's
ethan gets it because if you accuse
everybody at least
once at some point then at the end of
the game you can say see i called it
that's the big brain strat
i know dealer stay away from me she's
chasing me
i feel like i've seen jason do the admin
test twice
[ __ ] knew it i knew it was donkey
somebody killed
eddie bad i guess i think it was ela
i i hit here she walked in right here
right right she walked over from there i
kind of think
it's dunky has anybody seen damn
donkey following me i don't know what
he's talking about and it makes me
seriously suspect he's done the same
admin test
twice uh him repeatedly accusing me of
following him when i
i trust him i've even seen him in the
game he tells me he's he's trying to
divert wait
ian is sherlock holmes and i was with
him so
yeah yeah i think it's youtube
enjoy spaces enjoy space jason i like
your videos
oh i'm about to get murdered ela's
totally it
and she's following me it's totally ela
get the [ __ ] away from me me and
ian i think have both determined that we
need to follow evo
okay i called this meeting today
because we were all in the same area
fought me and ian were following ela to
because we suspect her
she walked over into navigation not at a
task just in the middle of the room
stayed still for about five seconds and
then
the co2 started beeping
uh i i definitely think it's elo and do
you have any uh
alibi whoa whoa whoa dan is not a
suspect right now either dan is not on
trial here
sorry you i love you enjoy space
just remember to meet your mic this time
good boys this time
dude if eddie kills in here it's going
to be [ __ ] oh
no well the med bay looks fancy
time to go to electrical and die
okay i want someone to see me scan
myself zach
come look at me oh come on get back here
okay gus is in here i trust gus
it's a very donkey play by the way to
pull the oxygen
come on muse do the thing oh no
i was trying to prove my innocence to
you
damn it
okay what's up i have fun
good thoughts huh well the the
the co2 pole immediately is a very
trademark move of jason
and additionally i was doing a
task and dunkey was about to stab me in
the [ __ ]
face but somebody called a meeting well
where's where what
this is what where they happened ethan
had a machine gun
wait where's the body yeah where's the
body maybe it's in the med bay i just
walked in there and found it
okay i saw jason on
in the storage room about i would say
20 seconds ago so i mean he could have
made it to the
table yeah i saw him in electrical maybe
right before that gus did
yeah you saw it when he was in there too
i thought when he's in there i'd be
shocked
to write when you i didn't see i was
still up there i don't think she's
shocked
if eddie softly on eddie i was gonna say
i literally was by myself i was like i
trust gus
i i feel like we've had um so i don't um
i definitely know i saw a couple of
names to the
far right around like o2 and navigation
who was over there as well
uh i've been with ila this whole round i
uh we did weapons together
and then so were you guys like in that
hallway at the end were you the names i
saw
yeah probably probably okay so who are
we unaccounted for right now so if it's
uh jason jason
he just went to kill his wife like that
on the first
that's well i don't i
who was in the like left to top left
area of the map
okay so i seen uh dunkey and i seen
zach um and i saw a b
yeah dan's also bottom left here
mm-hmm yeah fuel and refilling it was
dan
reactor yeah it was dan dan does the co2
a lot too so
yeah i think it was dan you were
refilling
dan is the imposter he has to go to
space
don't vote unless we have solid evidence
okay we might be voting out crew members
jesus christ all right well let's go get
these goddamn
jobs done what the hell dude what are
you guys doing
what is ap doing is he an imposter i
think yes
darn it [ __ ] i should have had a little
bit of defensive awareness there
it is without a doubt one hundred
percent zach
zach was following me followed me from
o2 i sprinted away from him for so long
stopped it comes
saw donkey in there crazy hold on oh gus
is dead too [ __ ] gus is the one
zach it's zach it's actually it's not a
hundred percent i buy it
i buy it i buy it i buy it
okay so i saw that it was like a mishap
i was on my way to go see what was what
do you mean a mishap
there was there was this talking about
but really what happened ethan is he was
sprinting behind me down the hallway
from o2
trying to kill me and then
[Music]
so dunky in there kept moving to the
left and i was like zach probably just
killed him right
walked back zach is in the hallway
standing at the body
it is okay hold on hold on
i'm just gonna trust eddie on this one i
know that it's not ian
and it's not ethan yeah i trust i trust
ian and elo so right now a b and a
were on my radar and a b a b reported
that body and zach was we absolutely
just got zach as one of the imposters
we just did you're wrong i think eddie
will set him up i think we got this one
that was some quick ass killing though
i'm kind of scared
i'm making pro gamer moves boys
somebody's going to take me out
i'm being too good you still have to do
your tasks when you're dead
this game always reminds me of the old
pop-up games that i would click on when
i was a kid in school because it was
like
shoot the blaster and i'd be like i know
it's going to give me a virus but i
really do want to shoot that blaster
though
ah ian thank you please don't kill me
in there's ethan and ela ethan go call
it ethan eddie call a meeting
too much time's gone by dude god damn it
there's a bee gonna follow him
oh ethan's [ __ ] dude
uh-oh get out of there dude they're
gonna win
did he just self-report oh my gosh
it's a b i'm pretty sure it's av that's
the second reported body ian and elo
were around me the whole game that
didn't kill me
he's very suspicious yeah what do you
got to say dude i mean i don't really
know how to defend myself i just seen
ethan i reported it
i don't know i was going to fix the
oxygen and i seen ethan's body
gus i know you can hear me this one's
for you buddy
my man i know i made the right move when
i wifed up eddie
there we go adam that one was for you
guys
maybe that didn't feel good man i was
going to fix the auction you snapped my
neck that's
bad luck dude that was a killing spree
holy [ __ ]
i was i almost called the emergency on
ab2 but i was like let's not be crazy
here i don't have the full proof
i'm going to see if i
i was trying to prove my innocence back
in the medical place
well i killed you i knew it was going to
be just
like a big like killing spree with no
strategy being mean zach
terrified in those hallways dude i was
like i gotta get away from him
[Music]
all right let's do this i'm just gonna
go
far as hell
the lights are out i'm scared oh god i
just got killed
[Music]
i have no information
i saw leah and someone else but it was
dark with eddie
me and eddie went to fix flights where
is this
uh it was the bottom like left corner
maybe did you kill that person that you
found
no i did not but i did see
ethan no you did it no you didn't
but you were going in a different
direction he was going in a different
direction though
it's interesting that he saw him there
he didn't see
i was with leah and you saw me right leo
oh leah the lights were up i never saw
you
how would i know you were at lights then
you didn't use that lights when it
started all right
whatever yeah yeah i will say
it was dark i will say right out the
gates i went to my first job and ethan
just like
stood in the room for like 10 seconds
and then left
you could feel freaking clear i can
clear guts i know
when the lights were it was fixed lights
i saw gus walk up into the top right so
there's no way he killed dan
i mean yeah i was doing the telescope
job up there
it's not me when me and eve went into my
friend
people would call him evil ethan so i'm
just putting that out there
i won most evil for the yearbook it was
weird that they even had that category
when i was in school we had a category
called class chow hound and they gave it
to like the largest kid in class and it
was nothing but it's so
[ __ ] up what the [ __ ] awful chow hound
bigot most likely to die of a heart
attack oh man i didn't even need to go
in here what am i doing in here dude
all right nobody's calling emergencies
whoever it is
so somebody who would not call
emergencies
where's everyone
oh [ __ ] you
oh dude i totally thought ila was gonna
murk my ass there
give me the [ __ ] out of here ethan don't
leave me alone don't leave me alone with
that kick
huh
dude i always totally thought i was
going to die right there i thought hilo
was going to murk me
how the hell do you get over there jesus
christ
purple where the hell did you come from
but why is her body here
thousand percent leah just are standing
over the blue body okay listen
this is cranky but
i'm standing here doing weird tasks and
it just keeps saying
required reboot required and then i was
like maybe i have to turn in the lights
because the lights are broken to do this
task
and so when i close the task window i
see this body under me
okay all i could say is that i was with
eddie and gus while i was around them so
i don't think it was them
um near the electrical area i'm sorry to
add this
but also i what was going on with the
lights with you because i
i waited for you to do it for a long
time and then you didn't fix the lights
and walked away
well i think i think anyone could vouch
for me then i just don't know what the
hell i'm doing
okay also i want to mention if if you
have some of that sauce eddie
a b was the last person that i saw
besides
leah and he was definitely running
completely away from the lights there
okay he got beneath my feet i'm serious
that's kind of i don't know if that
defense holds up
that like oh wait jason you were dead
body standing
there wait jason when i got in here but
jason what happened when you and ethan
were in that room with me and i left
because the lights you both were
standing still
and then the lights went off and i left
and now ethan's dead
but then i left i went towards the
bottom left
okay didn't even see him there and i saw
nobody
okay gus what do you think what do you
think from leah's story
it sounds like a great story and it's
true specific
and i also saw that though so
god well okay here's the thing pretty
much right away
ela was chasing me the [ __ ] down i was
trying to go i did a double loop
by the button and i was trying to hit it
i don't know why it wasn't hitting but
someone must have just started the
lights
trying to like do the game with you
man i really
damn it okay well nobody skipped so
baby's gone so we're either gonna lose
immediately or we have a lot of time
right
okay oh it's totally get the [ __ ]
go away get out of here what are you
doing get the [ __ ] out of here dude
[ __ ] you dude jason [ __ ] off dude
uh-uh not happening
come on guys come on guys somebody get
the [ __ ] second one
eddie killed her and he killed her and i
just watched him right in front of me
james
because she was standing at me at the
reactor the whole time you guys are all
confused you guys are
what did they call eddie in high school
[ __ ] murderer eddie
i don't know i mean that's a good point
dude i was like i'd vote me
i was terrified okay i really i can't
even talk
what
okay
[Music]
and i opened it up and he was just
flipping them on and off so the lights
would be there as long as possible and i
was like there's no way
see i'm literally hiding under this
stupid card if you look at my character
dude i was like screaming for 30 seconds
on my end because
donkey was just
it's like the emergency was going on and
the only like we were the only two other
people i was just going
on the other side of the map
i hate zach i just hope i don't die
right away
if that happens to me again then bruh
zach's about to murder me yep
okay um i just walked into med bay
and found a dead body on the scanners
dance oh
so sad i believe zach there
[Music]
that is a zack movie it could be on the
scanner
i've seen i've been with eddie and gus
primarily
i was in the security yeah i was not i
didn't
know that's that i well i was crossing
over um
he ethan whoa the pizza i'm not gonna
lie the pizza just got here
okay well everyone else it was a super
cold body cause ethan you saw me across
from cafeteria i didn't see
zach heading anywhere from a suspicious
spot there i don't know though
i just i know gus and abe were
definitely an admin ethan you were
walking from that direction and you just
accused zach and voted immediately
i think ethan wants to die to be honest
he wants to have pizza so
i think he wants to say pizza and i
think he's the imposter because he's
walking away from med bag
i'd also be mega shocked if it were
eddie because he would have had to kill
and immediately self-report and he
basically never does that i
literally don't know the hotkeys yet
because me and ayla were together
for quite a while ethan was walking out
of that hallway into the cafeteria and i
found the body and he voted zach
immediately yeah sorry
out of the hallway into the cafeteria
from med bay i didn't see there was
anyone else coming from that direction
jason just trust me at least you jason
jason you got my back right
yeah yeah
tell me who it is it's zach zack all
right
thank you buddy hey you voted
[Laughter]
[Music]
food